good morning Millennials chic c'est la
vie
so mom say mom yes I do speak French how
was your night I guess that was your
like I'm paying the price now like I'm
in shambles oh is that why you don't
feel well a break for 20 no but I didn't
know you were hungover I just thought
you were completely I'm so hungover cuz
I really actually like having a drink in
a while but like I've not seen Sunday I
couldn't be tamed like I would think it
was drunker last night than I was at
your wedding
really I wasn't even that drunk are you
running I was just tired that's so crazy
that you're here then that's what I'm
saying okay now I understand why why
I've been annoying right um no but but I
love when I do the show hungover like it
makes for good I cancelled all my
appointments it's it when you do the
show with a concussion you just never
know what you're gonna say Yad you've
been really spiraling this week and it's
because of your concussion yeah if I say
how you feeling by the way I feel okay
my head still hurts too actually
less so I'm feeling a lot better I think
I'm out of the woods am I out of the
woods yeah but you can weigh the next uh
Billy what's that guy's name
OxiClean Billy um Billy OxiClean yeah
dude he ate his head he was seeing his
luggage out on the plane hit his head
died the next time no yeah that's why
they got the new guy that's I didn't
rapture he died yes airplane that's very
fast tbg wrote about did you see on GMA
Sully met Sully no so the dog dog whose
namesake is Sully Sullenberger met Sully
the dog Wow double the pit for me yeah
cuz I never got my photo from the mean
green and like silly dogs he did or
peanut following he doesn't even know
usually I have this stream pulled up but
it's so distracting today like I can't
but like when I'm not watching the
stream about that comment slowing I'm
like oh we're not on the air you know
yeah we're on the air people are
enjoying my boots and my sweater
Billy Mays Sorry Sorry so I gotta sit
like this Billy Mays I just want to
point out that two days in a row I wore
heels yes and wear heels yesterday for a
meeting that was cancelled thank you
guys so much by the way the people who
canceled on me are still
but so I had to rewear the shoes today
but I wear heels every day yeah we do a
lot of hate we look this nice every day
you can pay for it down yeah just like
so the show was great
countess you know I saw the first
countess show ever I liked exactly yeah
go but I never got to recap it she's
really had the same trajectory as your
tour started in February went around the
world Habakkuk only works to anyone who
would listen last night oh but I'm like
she's really like uh she goes to markets
and tests them for me because where she
goes I go because it's like the same
audience yeah love it so how was the
show show was great the show was
definitely evolved since I last saw it
when I first taught you listen one of
her songs now she sings all three thank
God
she's gotten more comfortable on stage
same Giovanni fashions they did a Q&A
and obviously I asked a question and I
live stream did you watch my live stream
I saw it in the toaster it was so
incredibly let they asked Margaret to
ask a question and me and then also
Aviva asked a question and honestly like
when Aviva spoke I was like stop she
goes I guess so darling she goes how are
you surviving those [ __ ] without me
and I'm like she's doing just fine Aviva
thank you
but if he was actually something I see
backstage I should stop talking shed I
have got to stop talking chat speaking
of talking [ __ ] and needing to put our
foot in our mouths today is a very
special day because we have a guest
someone who has really been a
cornerstone of it so forward yeah of
this show he's actually the inspiration
behind our baskets Nick abaya will be
joining us I don't really have anything
else to say because I'm honestly really
scared I'm really scared here we're
going from talking [ __ ] to eating [ __ ]
literally my favorite with a little
cherry on top so that'll be later in the
show everyone gird your loins I think
it's me I actually have no idea how it's
gonna go it's gonna be incredibly
anxious fulfilling I think yeah but just
keep your hand on that mute button Jake
just in case he goes off cuz he really
good he really good
and rightfully so um anyways so much
news is going on - the world doesn't
stop turning so I think it's time to
just jump right in to the past five
stories thing you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast okay obviously our number
one split actually you know what sorry
before we do that a message from our
sponsors by the way did you ever use
headspace yes it's like a meditating app
Olivia made me use it in LA like two
years ago and I'm like oh she's great
and I literally had the best sleep of my
life and now Ben has started to use a
noise machine and he's like trying new
things and I made him use headspace and
he loves it people really swear by
meditation and noise machine for
sleeping I do so did you know that three
weeks of headspace can reduce your
aggression reactivity to negative
feedback by 57 percent Wow I've only
been doing it for like two weeks but
maybe in one week I'll be a lot nicer
nicaya won't want to yell at me
maybe maybe hopefully he's had space on
his way over here headspace is hundreds
of meditation sessions on everything
from stress to sleep start your journey
towards a healthier happier life by
subscribing to headspace sign up now at
head space.com slash toast to get a free
month trial sign up online at headspace
calm / toast for a free month trial
start meditating today exciting yeah
okay story number one Jessie smaller
this under arrest for allegedly lying
about the hate attack
Jessie smell it who we here on the
morning toasting sorry I don't know just
smelling smell it because he was very
very messy in his staging his own hate
crime this is the thing I've never
staged a hate crime but I do have some
tips if you're looking to do it do a lot
better than Jesse did Jesse sorry Muffy
whatever
I really wish his name was Jesse just so
when we made up our nickname it could
have been messy like no I mean a lot
funnier because I feel like Jackie I was
laughing about musky smell a Oh Rock yes
but so if you're gonna seed your own
hate crime here's what I suggest
definitely pay cash for the new serie
buying because then a receipt literally
a receipt will follow you around I would
say don't hang out and take pictures
with the people who you're staging it
with like a couple days before the
meeting on public Instagram I and people
like on Craigslist but don't go on the
internet but find randoms
yes who are like you know that movie to
strangers on a train
what's that movie called I've never
heard I think it's called to something
to girl on a train to strangers on a
train I need to commit the crime for the
other person but it the only way they
knew each other is because they sat on
the train together every morning but
their lives are completely separate One
Killed one's wife wasn't killed the
other wife and then they finally
realized they knew each other from
riding the train together people see
movie sliding doors no me neither but in
my communications class someone
referenced it and they always think
about it and I feel like I saw the movie
it's basically like Gweneth Paltrow a
close personal friend of mine she gets
on a train and the movie is like dual
lives what would have happened if she
missed this train or if you
the next one and like she gots a haircut
so you know what it's like the old one
and the new one and it's so crazy I
think she laid eyes in one of them Wow
is that crazy I like mess with your
brain like shutter island' that's how we
start we gotta get back on toast movie
of the week
maybe sliding doors and two strangers
out yeah I actually want to see sliding
doors and there was weirdly a master
post about it in one of the the toast
groups a little while ago people were
like acting like it's a movie that
changed your lives like a life needs to
be changed let's get back to Joe's maybe
the week next week I have too much on my
plate and I never did the last one
Seabiscuit we couldn't secretary you
couldn't remember if we had a sign -
Seabiscuit or Secretariat because
they're both one word in movies that
start with s about horses odds of them
winning
mazi Smollett who has been charged with
lying to cops when he claimed to be the
victim of a racist and homophobic attack
turns himself into Chicago police early
Thursday loser
Jesse Smollett is under arrest in
custody of detectives who had earlier
contacting the 36 year old attorney to
negotiate a reasonable surrender for his
arrest Chicago Police spokesman Andy
googly googly L niece tweeted the Empire
actor was charged Wednesday with felony
disorderly conduct for the allegedly
false report he made January 29th
according to the Cook County State
Attorney's Office okay so like I know
that when you get arrested it has to be
like for a specific crime I don't
understand how staging your own hate
crime is a disorderly conduct charge
I don't know but filing a fake police
report yeah for sure sorry look what
about you know I'm [ __ ] up the
emotions of millions of Americans like
what about that that's not a crime okay
what is this a crime being a thirsty on
GMA with Robin Roberts even though she
knows you're [ __ ] lying
technically not a crime but fraud is a
crime yeah in false false impersonation
of a hate crime something I don't know
it just sort of Lee contact like that's
what Snooki got which got a rest on the
beach this is bright this is more than
that like she just shut by the way that
episode where jukka gets arrested and
then they're all back at home calling
her parents trying to remember what it
is that she got arrested for and tell
that they couldn't remember J Wells like
public intoxication of disorder that's
so funny and I think couldn't remember
but she got arrested for Giovanni know
if I ever get arrested not gonna that
that never happens because I don't think
I would survive in jail I would totally
be for like Jung
disorderly conduct whatever it's called
yeah like but so how pretty the rest of
the state way messy no I don't know and
then also this is going down to a grand
jury so it's like is he gonna have to be
proven again or wholly reliable juror
system all these rural jurors just
[ __ ] it up they can never get it
right I need to get energy but I think
like the most justice will be served
like in the court of public opinion you
know because this must-see is finished
he'll never work in this town again
literally even though he hasn't Empire
hasn't said anything about writing them
off right well that was gonna be my next
story because Empire producers are
reportedly weighing whether to suspend
lessee Smollett what's really weird and
pirates way not me Empire producers are
reportedly weighing whether to suspend
message Smollett now that he's been
charged with fibers boxing support
sources close to the show told variety I
- a night that Fox p.m. mulling over a
possible punishment for smell it after
his racist attack story was officially
denounced by Chicago authorities the
network had been standing firmly behind
the actor issuing a statement earlier in
the day that said he was still
considered quote a consummate
professional unfed and wasn't being
quote written out of the show despite
reports saying otherwise
one production source told variety that
smell it was scheduled to be on the
Chicago side of empire this Thursday
today the same day he's scheduled in
court but the producers are not planning
on changing their shooting schedule but
and you know what's weird is like
everything started um people were saying
that muskie sages attacked because he
was being written off of Empire so he
wanted like starter eyes he starte
arrives because how can that how can you
write off my see now everyone's turning
into great to watch Messi right so it's
almost like the Empire producers don't
want to prove that it's true that that
was a possibility right what I'm saying
technically like they could be like to
blame even though there's really only
one person to blame yeah it's like this
wouldn't have happened if you were gonna
write him off right so it's weird it's
just Hollywood it's just always doing
the wrong thing but no you're so right
like I think I would prefer in this case
like if I could only have one
I would prefer the court of public
opinion to denounce Jesse than like him
actually go to jail to know any mean
right cuz I give it goes to jail and
then comes that guy's a hero you know
he's also think the punishment fits the
crime it's like he only hurt himself
seriously so it's like what he really
did was sway public opinion so he
held up in the court of public opinion
yeah no I just I wonder why they're
being so shady and not really saying
anything in terms of him being on Empire
I don't know does he play on Empire
Margo do you want he plays the son one
of the kids I've seen a few episodes you
have when I saw that with Olivia it was
always loves that show really influenced
her like and her style and like how
she's like started acting yes she was
she's cookie yeah she's so cookie
I love cookie even though I don't even
know her else they'll just love cookies
yeah so I'll be interested I was
watching all these new different news
outlets yesterday trying to seek is that
when we covered the story I've been you
know I would got married this weekend so
I've been kind of out of touch so
congratulations right how are people
handling the story it is so sensitive
because I'm the one hand if if he's not
lying and we even put out there that
he's lying like were [ __ ] but if he
is lying like we're all look like
[ __ ] what a loser you know so I just
I didn't know how other outlets we're
gonna cover it and everyone is in our
same predicament and so many people like
refused to say anything until the
gauntlet has been thrown and with the
garm that has it through though this
morning he turns oh man there's a mug
shot there's a messy mug shot I
absolutely love celebrity mug shots like
it is my favorite pastime I collect them
like we should open a museum yeah just
like blown up celebrity hit and I think
there's a lot of celebrities who like in
their days have been arrested for one
thing or another like you don't really
think of them as like criminals like I
was doing anything celebrity mugshot you
think like Lindsay Lohan right but I
don't know I think we need to open a
gallery no there are some people who
have just been like evacuated by hotel
security and they got their picture
taken in the basement right I'm shot or
like someone like you know getting
arrested for Greenpeace or whatever you
know like protesting
I'm getting a news notification musty
smell it allegedly paid $3,500 to stage
the attack because he was unhappy with
his salary
say the police so you're unhappy with
your salary you're giving away thirty
five hundred dollars I don't get it this
is from people Empire accuracy smell of
allegedly paid $3,500 to sage opposed to
a bogus hate crime against him because
he was this salad dissatisfied with his
salary Chicago Police superhero miss any
of you guys watch daily pop yesterday
Melanie Bromley
fumbled through the teleprompter and
they and they brought her on to do the
teleprompter
and I was like what and now it's
contagious now the president floods are
contagious Chicago Police Superintendent
editing Johnson said at a Thursday press
conference that's what I get for making
fun very small at 36 was charged with
filing filing a false police report
about his alleged attack on Wednesday so
I guess he thought if this happened to
him his star would rise if he ever tried
to walk away from the show they would
pay him more I mean like I just feel
like there's other ways to go about
raising your salary I mean they
literally like they they have
motivational videos of like what you do
like to go to your boss yes you do a
power pose in the bathroom please hi
gratuities watch all of those videos I
power pose before my shows I used to
power pose in the bathroom and then like
ya know you used to practice rehearse
and then do none of it okay maybe they
can go at you right let's talk myself
I'm not giving my all
let's talk my salary for wasting your
time so anyways like there definitely
other ways to go about it you know he
could have been in like a thirsty
Instagram relationship no there are
other ways to get your star to rise this
is extreme I can't I can't just take a
note out of the Nick and Priyanka buck
like just get married I can't I can't
personify I can't conclude this story
like this story when I give this story I
think of one word loser loser
get a life whose time to say you a crime
I'm too hungover someone made a really
fair point Katie passed Murray I miss
Claudia reading the stories the ridicule
was more balanced I never read the story
yes you did back in the day with me and
a teleprompter you used to read the
stories oh my god my eyesight is so bad
both make fun of each other now it's
just on me and it's hello Heather day
that is so true like I never really do
you even know how unclear Tiki watching
New Jersey last night oh my god
Jackie I literally was about to be like
speaking people yeah
we have to talk about it I know well
okay well recap it before neck file
because it was crazy and I did watch The
Bachelor and there was still no friends
so there's nothing to recap until
there's a fence I'm not interested until
there's defense I'm on the fence
obviously okay
Khloe Kardashian breaks her silence on
Jordan woods tristan cheating scandal
since yesterday it has been 99.9%
confirmed that this did happen
Kim unfollowed Caitlin followed both of
them Chloe posted some majorly emo quote
cards on her Instagram story this
morning saying that a betrayal is so
much more painful when the person who
betrayed you is the person you explained
your pain to a gym by lon said it was
confirmed on her talk show and we know
she has close Kardashian sources and she
said she spoke to her sources and it is
confirmed she didn't leave a shadow of
it out Morgan Stewart on Daly pops said
that she had spoken to Chloe and she
promised to drag Jordan on the show
meaning that Chloe endorsed a dragging
him Jordan Chuck wait Morgan knows Chloe
yes yeah I'm jealous
yeah so this really happened and now
what I'm thinking is it's worse than
what we saw because we thought that they
were possibly in love and they're gonna
run away together we've been thinking
that we said it's the only way though
it's the only way that this could like
for her to have done this but what it
seems like is like a sloppy party
makeout dancefloor makeout session that
people saw in public and they just like
we're sloppy and stupid and messy they
were [ __ ] messy as hell that know
everyone's being messy as [ __ ] to speak
and they have to get their stuff
together and clean the [ __ ] up but
that's what I'm saying Esther like if
all of this was just like a drug mistake
like her whole life like job car salary
family everything fell apart just for
one drunken mistake and I don't even
know that they had sex I they might have
just been missing out Wow
horrifying Wow Jordan just Wow Khloe
Kardashian has broken her silence about
Tristan Thompson cheating on her with
Jordan Woods taking to her instagram
story Chloe posted not so cryptic
quotations that were unmistakeably
directed at Kylie Jenner's best friend
and her now as boyfriend quote the worst
pain is getting hurt by a person you
explained her hurt - damn it appears the
EBIT star might be grateful for woods
and Thompson's actions as she then
posted somebody needs to hear this that
betrayal was your blessing her final
quote seemed to be a direct jab at her
unfaithful ex if they ask you about me
tell them she was the only person that
loved me with honesty and I broke her
she is like so emotional and so sad and
I just have to say like she has horrible
taste in men
she's got to stop doing all these
horrible luck she is another one who
needs a businessman beau she should be
dating that kicky Ben yeah
totally they can't buy a million-dollar
house with eqr know what's the thing
called a tepee a palapa yeah yeah a plop
Oh plop oh yeah
just have you no tikis by the Tiki I'd
have a Kiki rekey okay yeah she she
needs to meet new people do nobody here
usually get on Jase wife you know like
nice and nice good dating apps like what
where I mostly she's Margaret's like our
guinea pig 18 year old like we asked her
homeworld knows nothing about dating and
she's 21 like if you are of age and have
a penis like please but my my number one
recommendation pretty anyhow is hinge
yeah I think so too this is a sponsored
I'm generally just carry no yeah that's
Zack and I like met a little bit on
hinge hinge plus work but we had matched
on hinge which let us both know that we
were both single and straight you know
that's where it's helpful just like
making clear like labels for people even
though you're not supposed to Lydon but
like what are gonna waste your time on
someone like who's married right well
yeah or does not even looking like not
even on meeting I'm not interested right
or gay right perfectly knowing okay oh
my god wait they were actually sorry I
never met you know they don't wanna
share the story um next story just in
you know this series of stories is that
Kim Kardashian has officially unfollowed
Jordan Woods and Tristan Thompson I made
a cheating allegation and whoever
discovered this did it the right way I
can't with everyone and their fake outs
like she unfollowed no I spoke about
this yesterday there's a way to check if
someone still follows them and it
doesn't include searching their
followers it includes searching their
following I mean you can always count on
Kim to be the toughest on his cheating
men I'm just like I'm thinking of Kylie
in this dark time only Kylie she must be
devastated
and you know what's crazier because okay
so it wasn't an affair that they were
having they're not in love they're not
running away together it was a stupid
dance floor make out that like I'm sure
Jordan feels awful about and like I
don't know if Kylie will forgive her
ever could forgive her but it's like she
has the option to forgive her you know
but can she
Hollywood unlock just announced that
Jordan and Tristan Thompson have been
involved for over a month comes reporter
from the field directly snitch you guys
counselor what the [ __ ] is Hollywood
unlocked and when did it become
associated for us
okay I saw something about Hollywood
unlocked but the person who runs it I
guess it's just his friends of the
Kardashians
some random morning show it's friends
with the Kardashians okay honestly I'm
relieved that they've been involved for
over a month for her sake because if it
was just a mistake like she would be
begging for forgiveness for the rest of
her life but you know what now and you
know maybe she didn't know what she was
doing but she knew what she was doing
and she made her bed and now she's gonna
sleep in it and it's not it's not gonna
be alone and it's not gonna be alone and
it's not gonna be on a Kardashian so
maybe they are in love okay that's still
a possibility Wow it's not in Calabasas
okay now see hotels calm now this is
Tommy sicko Telecom know being shady as
[ __ ] on Twitter if you're looking for a
hotel in the Calabasas area and they put
up a link to all the Calabasas hotels
for Jordan yeah that's nice funny when
brands have humor but she wouldn't have
even seen it because Kris cut off her
phone service right you know they took
her phone away right everyone's like why
is Jordan so silent it's good she can't
get to us yet her phone she gotta start
a new flinch you gotta go over a sprint
you know Cricket Wireless for her yeah
tough times she didn't just lose oh my
god any scene and the comments people
are leaving under the Kylie X Jordan
collab on Kylie cosmetics calm you can
review the product like where the story
prom it was amazing didn't stick they're
like perfect for a night out of doing
shady things with your best friend's
sister's boyfriend
Wow yeah I mean this like the Internet
is really show the Internet can be a
terrible place but in moments like this
like the creativity is just yeah it
knows no bounds and I'm loving all
because honestly when I thought it was
just a makeout I thought Kylie might
forgive her like because it you may be
good but this is unforgivable and I'm
glad but I'm sad for Kylie but now she
knows the kind of like Jordan really is
like [ __ ] up big she like didn't just
make a mistake she made a mistake I just
will never be able to wrap my head
around why it's like I'm just this
confused about this like why someone why
Jordan would do this justice confuse and
I was like why Jesse would I'm sorry
Leslie
would do that like I'm just as perplexed
by talking now it's not what's more
shocking what's more difficult to
understand like what's less relatable
like have like literally biting the hand
that feeds
or CG a hate crime still the musky thing
wins but still this is a close second
yeah big time craziness big miss know
what this is it's a big mistake huge the
biggest okay next story any to go
grocery shopping in a little morning
show host news I mean same I've been
eating like all this like expensive
chocolates that were said into my hotel
room during my wedding like no but it's
like all these ones with like strawberry
filling we by the way all the ones did
you did you see the flowers or the candy
for him mohandro that's what I've been
eating I never know if you got it cuz
like I learned like you know I didn't
tell you um
no last night I got home like drunk so
hungry and all there was was like skinny
pop and you just start ordering food but
like I don't want this crap in my body
you know you don't
Jimmie's thrive marketplace actually
learned about it on Instagram from I
think I Madison yeah I say they do they
work with influencers yeah here and now
they are well they basically send
groceries straight to your door but it's
all like good [ __ ] like they have big
kosher stuff they have paleo they've
keto you could like shop categorically
like Ben would be like checking all the
boxes like keto kosher Wow
yeah he doe kosher that leaves like two
things yet that sounds so good so it's
an online marketplace with a mission to
make healthy living easy and affordable
for everyone you can buy brands you
trust for 25 to 50% off traditional
retail prices you can shop for non-gmo
food snacks vitamins supplements
personal care products eco-friendly
cleaning supplies safe and non-toxic
beauty products and so much more you can
filter by values like vegan kosher
ketogenic gluten free make healthier
choices even if you don't follow a
strict diet
we even offer for the toasters you can
get 25% off your first order and a free
30-day trial so they're pregnant prices
are ready 25 to 50% off and then they're
giving you another 25% off
I'm thrive market calm / toast no Coke
necessary the discounts automatically
apply to check out thrive market calm /
toast I'm gonna use the code actually
I'm gonna do that bit next week cuz I'm
still eating like my way I was gonna say
to like are you like you were on this
wedding diet how many how is how long is
the cheat week and I think it'll go
through the weekend I can't just like
one day wake up and decide to be good
again but also I feel like I haven't
been fulfilled you know I need to go out
to a delicious meal that was my big plan
you know what maybe I'll do that but
then I have to go out right that's the
hard part about going out coming here is
the going out part right so we'll see
coming to work is hard enough but when I
get back on
I'm going to do and like I think I want
to kind of stay in good shape like at
least have like one good summer you know
I know carol has 20 but yeah I guess
Neil is five I just bought one oh right
he has 20 yeah she has side I by my
calculations I think last one last
summer was her last one right we'll see
this summer maybe she got a bonus one
yeah okay next story in a little daytime
talk show host in little host news Wendy
Williams announces returned to her show
after more than 2 month hiatus it's been
two months it's been so long
Wendy Williams is returning to TV
Williams has been on hiatus from the
Wendy Williams Show since December but
will finally return to host on March 4th
Wendy Williams is an incredible talent
with the most unique voice in daytime
the show's production company dad Marv
mercury said in a statement on Thursday
we can't wait to welcome her back to her
iconic purple chair on the set of her
show the statement continued we so
appreciate all the guest hosts and
panelists who filled in for Wendy during
this time these people are and will
always be true family to the show and we
want to thank all the loyal and
supportive fans who have been with us
for 10 years now
Williams took a hiatus from her morning
show to treat her Graves disease
she was Hospital long hospitalized long
term but then was spotted out with a
friend at CBS in Florida rumors about
her husband's alleged infidelity or
abuse began to swirl as her absence
continued while she was taking care of
herself Nick Cannon Michael Rapaport
Aereo Connell and more guests filled in
for her as hosts I mean this story is
just it's so weird but I'm more so you
know insulted that we were in a stir
house I found my lipgloss my sweater at
the whole time
amazing what is it it Laurie I know I
wish it's Luna and Astor I think it's
like blue Mercury's own brand it's cute
it is cute I'll take something I've worn
at my wedding
did you know it's crazy I wore Kylie
cosmetics at my wedding tell her passion
the lipstick that's the color I was
wearing it's I'm wearing it now too
I wore NYX I mean everyone's yelling me
for how to pronounce that what do you
say I guess it makes it depends what I
say the NYX wonder stick but I could if
I'm really I say the NYX would you still
use them I understand I only use the
contour side though yeah I don't use a
contour stick anymore either the
highlight stick no I don't use the the
dark part I don't kind of cream anymore
oh that's all I do
oh really but some of these have forget
I don't know why it's like the first
step I forget anyways back to money
billions she's back she's back I'm so in
the dark and confused as to what's going
on I know there's a lot of rumors
swirling but I haven't really been
keeping up on it
I've been like planning weddings so um
do you want to fill me in um yes so she
does have Graves disease her husband is
notoriously disloyal they have a toxic
relationship she fainted on stage and
that's all I know right so then she took
some time off and then there was just
like I can't get over how incredibly
[ __ ] up but is that her fainting is
like one of the most used gifs on the
Internet gifts is it and yes oh my god I
see it all over Twitter that was crazy
that was crazy that's like my worst
nightmare like every time I have to like
fart I have to run off so when she comes
back like what do you think I guess
she'll probably just is she gonna
address it I mean I'm sure she will but
I don't think you'll get any sort of T
that you're looking for no me neither
and that's annoying because I'm always
looking for to write constantly on the
search for glass of chamomile tea she
appreciates good tea so yeah I just
really liked her show I mean I'm
obviously never forgive her for what she
did to Rachel Lindsay and I'm still like
really mad about it but I think that she
has good takes on celebrity culture and
she doesn't let her relationships with
certain celebrities influence what she
talks about and look at how she speaks
about it
and I like her show and if it's if it's
on and I'm home and there's nothing else
on I'll watch it so I'm excited for her
to be back I guess yeah unless she's
taking over their competition no but
she's daytime you know she's much later
in the day and let's be real there's no
competition with the morning toast okay
we're a little early which will also
segue us into Real Housewives of New
Jersey we mean recap Danielle Staub and
Marty Caffrey to finalize divorce in
court the marriage of Real Housewives
New Jersey semi star Danielle Staub and
Martin Caffrey will be finally over on
Thursday page six is learned
we're told the pair expected to appear
before a judge in a Bergen County
courtroom at 9:00 a.m. to end their
dismal 10-month Union we're told the
split is uncontested and they anticipate
that the appearance will last less than
an hour a source who seen the divorce
documents tell us that as part of the
agreement stabbed will have to either by
the 2.15 million dollar house that they
have been living in together or move out
by April she'll also have to cough up
for the furniture inside it if the house
is sold Caffrey will have to move out
immediately but until it sells he's
going to continue to live there Chuck
Matt stab also has to repay all her
debts to Caffrey and she has to return
all their wedding presents Caffrey's
never had any of them were told she has
to return them to the store or to him
but that's not their there both of their
present and then we're both married they
should split them 50/50 yeah Caffrey
told page six now that might've work
we'll be final I feel great relief as
well as sadness I bear Danielle no ill
will and I wish for the best in
everything she does he's previously
blamed the end of their marriage on the
Bravo show the pair married in May and
announced that they were splitting in
August I think that Marty and Joe and
Margaret are actually friends now yeah
that's what that's what I was getting
from when they all came on the show that
Marty was actually at one point living
with Margaret and Joe right and then
Danielle and Teresa was like yeah yeah
like I think he's a good guy he was
under a spell much like Teresa's okay
let's talk about the reading and because
all I could think was what is going on
with Teresa she was being like a spoiled
child and it's like the same thing el
that was in her you know no one tells
teresa giudice what to do spoke to her
before the ring and and said this is the
true pep talk this is the teresa giudice
show nobody talks to you and stays on
the show and then she literally just
blurted that same thing out well I'm
really struggling especially because the
whole episode was really truly severe
Jackie and when I look at it from a
third-party perspective completely with
no Teresa's wrong like whatever but I
just can't get behind Jackie like
there's something so inauthentic about
her and I just I'm not with it yet I
just I I it's not that I can't get
behind Jackie like I don't think she's
like a lovable character but she is so
rational and right and Teresa is so
wrong it's it's crazy and and I like
that someone's like yes everybody does
feel that way they like you can't cross
Teresa because like she went to jail so
the show is hers
somehow but I'd like that Jackie doesn't
care like Jackie would rather say her
truth than be on next season yeah I knew
and I think she will be on next season
me too I think they're both returning so
Teresa's wrong like and Teresa can't
feel like just because you know by the
way it's like she went to jail so the
show was hers but like you guys come
into the crime like why is that a good
thing so you need to be like proud of
that now you have a show right because
of it so and Teresa shouldn't feel like
no one can cross her like a saying she
never has to be held accountable then
she can do and say whatever she wants
and doesn't have to worry that people
are gonna come for her yeah I mean she
was saying some some weird [ __ ] when
Jackie was like all right so if I'm back
next season I won and that reason is
like no oh my god when Teresa was like
are you hungry
right after she just talked about her
experience with an eating disorder like
oh my god and I'm like this
she did I said she did not just say that
like what and then they got Jennifer
septon was like I think you mean
Thursday and I do think she didn't mean
thirsty I don't think she really meant
to say that but I like her ignorance was
what's not bliss it was not bliss
terrible and then when she started to
call Jackie you saw her because she went
to one meeting green and Jackie is so
[ __ ] smart she goes oh so that's what
you think about all the people who come
to your meetings just like honestly
that's what you get for having like a
smart lawyer on the show by the way the
only moment where Jackie was visibly
like gotten to and like enraged was when
they brought up the picture like but she
knew it was gonna be brought up so like
she was prepared and then when she
slipped it like that I was like wow does
Martin know that was some law daughter
type [ __ ]
it's crazy do you think all the people
who come to mingott osers right I mean
she was like there were four people in
line like she really turned the whole
thing around that was me I know that was
the days of what's what's her cookbook
called
fabulousness like there was every a line
around the block I know but she was just
as savage and she knew it was gonna come
up she knew that Teresa was kind of like
make her feel like a loser about it and
she just flipped it around and I have
the utmost respect for her ya know she's
really special is not helping yourself
and I love Teresa and like you know she
is the og of the NJ yeah but um she's
completely wrong she's acting like like
a petulant child no she really and it's
it's it's no one show like really you
think it's your show any Lisa Vanderpump
is on her way out of Beverly Hills
you're not safe in Jersey no nobody is
safe Vicki Gunvalson I think was demoted
to friend of housewife Lisa Vanderpump
has her own show on Bravo and she's
gonna be out of Beverly Hills did you
run over learn that they're gonna do
another show cuz she's opening a pump in
Vegas and they're gonna do another pump
roles great and you know what and I
don't think it would be as successful
because I think there's something the
Matt the secret magic sauce about
Vanderpump rules isn't the format its
history it's the group of friends they
just stumbled onto a goldmine if they
start doing that show in Vegas you're
never gonna find a group of friends that
knows each other that also works at a
restaurant that's just an open house so
have worked there for five years and
it's in Vegas yes it'll be Lindsay
Lohan's Beach Club then Chief Scott
Lindsay Lohan copied her and now she's
copying Lindsay Hoda Lee so I hope she
does that because I would love to see
her fail Jackie uh isn't that nice what
else happened at the Reunion melissa was
very quiet but there's definitely
something exploding the thing with the
family loyalty that Teresa kind of
demands
it's like in an argument that has
nothing to do with Melissa why why
charissa demands that Melissa it's like
take her side we by the way it's an
argument that has everything to do with
ERISA because Teresa I'm sorry Melissa
right Teresa is going in on Melissa like
the argument had everything to do with
with Melissa because Teresa's yelling at
Melissa
Jackie backs up Melissa and then Teresa
expects Melissa Teresa right it's like
Pythagorean theorem it's like it's
illogical yeah no I mean and then when I
have a compassionate it's like she
doesn't even she's so she's so not
accountable for the things that she says
and does it she doesn't even think about
okay I'm gonna say this about someone
let me just check my own backyard
yeah you don't speak to your sister for
years you didn't speak to your brother
in years and your sister-in-law
I have compassionate that was really sad
it was but like and it's like she
doesn't eat she she thinks she can just
speak like be wrong and say the wrong
things and it doesn't matter but like it
does and I have compassion I do like I
just feel like for a while Teresa could
get really got away with anything
because of what she was going through
and people were gonna be interested yeah
but now it's like that no longer applies
the chips have fallen where they may and
now you need to like be a housewife that
part of the team it's not the Teresa
show go get your own show if you know
you put you put the show on your back
and like your family drama really took
the show through some tough times the
twins and remark a sea of it all but now
the show has legs and it's no longer
like the success of the show is no
longer contingent on your you and your
husband's felonies so you've got to
bring something else on the table yeah
and maybe throw a wine glass I don't
know no or just something like rational
thinking thinking yeah I know what like
when I get past this hangover I'm going
to have the biggest migraine I'm sorry
you're my grand sister - no I I know but
I haven't had one since I've been re I
really think a lot of my migraines were
over the show oh you think oh yeah and I
knew it at the time um so we'll see how
I fare
anyone who's out of migraine knows that
they're the absolute worst they really
are like crippling cripplingly painful
not even painful cripplingly like
dizzying t building you just can't get I
bet it any time I would stand up now
it's a little easier to your
from the comfort of your own home thank
God thanks to cup Cove get treatment
from home soap starts out with a simple
consultation by a licensed physician and
then the prescription that they
determined is best for you is sent
directly to your door it's personalized
after your consultation your doctor
creates and tailors your individual
course of treatment
Kove then reaches out a few weeks after
seeing how you're feeling they break
down everything you need to know about
migraines migraine treatment a doctor
who's licensed to practice medicine in
your state will be the one who
prescribes your monthly medication
overseas your progress I mean I just
need this and the fact that you don't
have to leave your house like I deal if
you suffer from migraines the last thing
you need to have is to wait to see your
doctor with Cove there's finally a way
to get help you need when you need it
when you use our special link you'll get
first month of treatment for free go
with Cove calm slash toast with Cove WI
th Co viacom slash toes check it out
okay it's really so helpful now I'm
almost looking forward to my next
migraines but I'm not don't my [ __ ]
knock on wood chugging I'm like so
nervous because we have to bring the
file out I know what other shows were on
Jessie ah he's trying to stall know so
New Jersey I'm really looking forward to
the rest of me too something big is
brewing and just last night's episode
upset me because I just I didn't I
always will Santa Risa and I just I
thought she was really phoning it in and
and just saying this is the Teresa show
I can say and do what I want and I'm not
gonna be held accountable but you know
what we'll get 10 ml of ham and there
you will be held accountable tomorrow I
mean next week I believe is when she
announces that she has a boyfriend and
when we saw pictures of him less ieshua
jennice 26 and on his linkedin i think
it says an aspiring entrepreneur stabbed
stabbed what's his code for unemployed
okay we're gonna take a quick break we
are going to eat our [ __ ] put our [ __ ]
are our mouths and meet Nick vile I'm
like so nervous to meet him like
off-camera right I want to die okay so
yeah we'll be back in like two minutes
if you have a question feel free to
leave it on the YouTube stream and just
pray for us because I'm nervous and I
have diarrhea bye
you
welcome back to the newest episode of
eating [ __ ] with Jackie
duck we are here with someone who you
know we have just I think we've been
hard on we've been very hard on you and
more than I even realized yes yes I'm
sure
maybe wouldn't even realize when we came
up on your podcast you just said that
let's start from the really start from
beginning because we owe you an apology
I knew it
this is the morning apology with Jackie
and Claudia we we tried to trace back
how we started to just like be hard on
you it's our job to you know duck poke
fun and The Bachelor is one of the
things the bachelors write for it and we
had we knew vaguely from Andy season but
that was before we watch yeah we didn't
watch any season you didn't watch
anything no I watch it I was assuming it
was from Andy season well yeah that was
that moment that had gone viral like
that's the only thing we knew you from
right Oh Nick the villain right why is
he asking her on when two women tell all
that's what our personal questions right
so then we I started watching Krystal
season them Kaitlyn season you came on
and in my head you just like oh this
bill in this guy and we were Sean Bean
Kaitlyn's stands we will know here we
still are so we took sides but it was
just you know a normal thing that normal
just like a normal like oh I'm rooting
for Sean not it wasn't we weren't so
passionate about it yet then you went on
paradise right from there you go went on
paradise I'm Jen and we shipped you in
Jen hardcore we were like oh you know
what maybe he's not a bad guy right
because he left her high and dry
in the beach you know what she's doing
flying she is doing fine right in that
moment we were like oh this is his happy
ending he's not a villain anymore and
then he just like left her tonight on
The Bachelor right and then you can
imagine what was the timeline what do
you mean of when you broke up with Jen
and then when they asked you to be the
bachelor burger there in paradise
uh-huh and then they asked me like two
months later two months okay okay they
made it seem a little quicker than that
see just that well you watched it right
no they announce you as The Bachelor
before you broke up with artists so they
kind of put this in our heads that hold
on and we really did think you guys were
a great couple
Michelle screwed me we had also I mean
in hindsight this is hilarious we want
to take Lucas Jill I wanted taster backs
are and then they're like Nick I'm like
what how do you still feel about that
now will you follow him on Instagram Oh
big time we end
as if you know the right decision was
made but right now in time do you enjoy
those ass pictures yes no I mean we were
we were really saved with with we were
and we didn't know it at the time but
you know we used to know what they're
giving us and it's like okay so you're
this villainous person everything they
say about hindsight it's 20 20 20 so
yeah and then you ended up with Vanessa
who like we had known front like guys
you know the villain and they'll never
see chief up with Rachel and bimini even
an era and we were like these two people
so anyways then we just went in and we
took it a little far and then we we know
we choked but then and so we never even
spoke to you or maybe we were just like
jokingly like hating you and then Rachel
Lindsay who is a friend of the toast
went on your show and it's your show so
like you can say whatever you want and
she brought us up and you were like oh
those girls don't like me and like you
could have taken it as an opportunity to
just like slam us like there's so much
to me sad about us and you did it and I
was like oh all I have to do is not talk
[ __ ] yeah it was yeah yeah he's doing it
was like Oh a moment where we were like
maybe he's not a bad guy like cuz if
that was me and someone was talking [ __ ]
and I got my own show and I'm starting
to just you know what I gone ham Oh big
time but you did it and like if you had
gone him there would've been so many
people were like yeah those girls suck
but you didn't do it so I was like
movement of growth for us maybe there's
right maybe there's an opportunity to
talk [ __ ] but we really we grew up in
that moment I thought I mean I think you
look to your point I mean I guess I
could have spend it's my show Yeah right
I didn't know you guys I mean I've
clearly have realized you guys have a
very popular show by the way my cousin's
girlfriend Mary is very excited so hey
Mary I didn't know you existed until I
think it was you sort of trolling me on
my Instagram and I was like you know I
think you got the blue checkmark because
it was like cuz usually trolls are you
know there's no posts followers you know
this like weird cat me Bible verse in
their bio DEP 100% yeah and I was like
and then I kept looking like why is this
person really not like me when it
decides then I did some deep digging it
was I'm sorry it was a lie you know it's
it's
hard my job to just like be funny and
put fun but I took it too far
I apologize for trolling you I apologize
for what I said thank you for coming
first of all we love it I was like
wrestling when they write fine and they
would tag team up this is WWE Ross
SummerSlam basically yes it's winter
slam so did you accept our apology sure
okay thank you well so now that we get
to interview techniques personally from
people of the bachelor franchise you
kind of have gone the farthest I would
say just in terms of career afterwards
Thanks yeah so um are you doing January
Jones like were you ever
I mean she's a friend you guys I make
out yeah I mean hey I've learned my
lesson
right you're the one who I guess that's
true thank you that's my show tell us
sir yeah but so you have a new podcast
called the bio files which rate such a
good name love really yeah yeah I give
credit to my acting coach last producer
for coming up with that I wasn't sure
about it though how many how much of
your online trolls make fun of the fact
that your last name is vile it's vile oh
no he got it right it's a big thing my
mom's maiden name is Parker oh god I
wish Nick Parker from I know Pat Rapp
yes like a superhero name and I was like
you know if we get married it's fine you
don't have to take it no Nick Parker is
a great name sigh oh wow
it's supposed to be French it was
supposed to be like DV Tallis and
somewhere like you know an island island
island or whatever you know someone got
lazy and just like bunched it up and
Here I am very different very different
we how are you liking the podcast life
oh yeah I enjoy it it's fun I try to you
know we talked a little bit bachelor I
really honestly it's not meant to be a
bachelor pocket from time to time I'll
have people on like Rachael Ray's a good
friend she's cool and I'll give the
people what they want but ultimately
like I like talking I do like a lot of
relationship stuff I like talking about
other people's opinions I tend to have
people on it necessary
really I don't like I don't typically I
don't think it's that much fun to talk
to people who always agree with me yeah
so I think it's fun to have people have
different points of views a lot of my
guest hosts will be women because you
know I got the straight white guy thing
covered and check my opinion is covered
on that sense so my guest host would be
a variety of people prominent
predominantly women in various
industries and I've had one male guest
host Brad Goreski who's he's gay fashion
stylist who you know he gives a
different point of view so I just tried
to talk about like topical things
relationships dating and you know work
and we just get into it have some fun
fun well laying a little bachelor tee
here and there of course you are
watching Colton season oh yeah I like it
I like it
what do you call I think it's just
honestly think it's precious
you're just a sucker for a storyline I'm
sucker for a good virgin right now that
I think about we really are just like
sent we've been so molded by the batch
of razors we always like trying to say
about soundtracks get you when they
announced him you were fine with it we
got a lot of people the time work work
no we were in the minority of people who
were actually really excited about it
but I had some great guys he would have
been really happy with any of them yeah
you know kind of not so much
Oh what are your thoughts on Caitlyn
Jason great sure yeah do you know him I
I met him once he's a great guy yeah I
talked to Caitlyn but they seemed like
right to attractive people who would
like each other you know it kind of went
in after her and Shawn broke up you did
some podcast I forget which one it was
yours yes oh I thought it was one of the
cause my nose and bio files and you kind
of went in and Unleashed some things
that you wouldn't have ever spoken about
it had they've not broken up so much
unleashing it was just like a you know
my first guest host was Ashley Grace who
is a die-hard bachelor fan so we just
started talking about it she was very
excited we were talking about Colton
season and got into it and I was I kind
of fine
you know here we go and it's honestly
nothing really that juicy from my but it
was a lot of the behind the scenes that
kind of led to me going on that season
or all the stuff stuff happened during
that season that quite honestly I just
kind of shut my mouth because I
didn't know how much Sean you know
Caitlyn had told Sean you assume she
tells him everything but you never know
and I figured it might not go over well
had you know I just kind of was kind of
protecting her in that relationship
right again it's nothing like any
scandalous it's just how things went
down yeah you're very context for us
Henderson sure did you hear from her or
him no no I don't I don't know if she
was thrilled I don't think that uh but
you know she's welcome to come on my
podcast I don't think she I have a
question for you that I've been sitting
on for three years
yeah no this is such a good question no
it's not about you know when people are
like hey right I don't mean you make me
mad who is the country star but sean
booze with Eskimo brothers with during
your season that was a big storyline
I honestly don't remember liar I really
I really don't I'm not a country music
I'm not sure maybe that was Jackie's
theory the country's about but I really
don't know and truth is is that when
that was all going down this again I
think I might have said this but when I
was coming on I was very nervous because
I like I was coming for the girl I knew
that I was coming in has like the old
villain coming in late so like that is
not the recipe for life being Rovers
well-received and so I was really
nervous about these guys hate me like
but screw it like I like the girl but my
friend Ron from Andy season was friends
with Sean so I was going in thinking all
right well at least at least Ron's buddy
is there and I'll be friends with him
like the one guy and he was the one got
you in Sean just hated me he just like
he I met and the guys to my surprise the
guys were all really nice oh okay
whenever you're here it's cool yeah and
Sean was wouldn't talk to me he'd walk
past me I try to say hi he would just
keep ignoring make it and he he just
kind of throughout was quite honestly
just constantly talking [ __ ] I just got
annoyed and I wish I did it but I
finally I was just like when you see me
earring that I was like you hear the
other guys talking so I just I gave in
and I started talking [ __ ] too which was
dumb but I really don't remember I just
everyone's talking about everything I
mean like on cold season this whole like
well she said this
blah blah blah like sure like it's all
true like it's all like whatever though
- yeah right and there are those
conversations of who's gonna be the next
Bachelor about Charette in the house yes
yes of course I mean everyone's early on
everyone is you don't everyone's just
like what's going on you know everyone
is going in thinking in reality they're
like oh he had colds cute but like I
don't know if I like them great thing
and certainly there's gonna be
conversations well this is crazy we
should be friends we should hang out
afterwards of the show and we don't win
or way like of course there's
conversations like that and then what
happens like two or three Slater a lot
of the people get sucked in and they're
all in so I absolutely believe that some
version of what they're like Cassie and
Caitlyn are being accused of happened I
also like also think they're sincere
yeah I also think they absolutely in the
moment or like I love Colton I want to
be with them like you can it can be both
and because in two weeks like that it
feels like a year and then yeah
and it's a lot of gotcha moments like
again like when I was on Caitlyn season
literally everything I was coming on my
mouth the guys were like especially Sean
were just like what can he say right -
like you know oh you know like you know
a lot of gotcha moments so it's you're
just caught up in that world pressures
are high everyone is just and and at
this point the season everyone's on edge
because it's like make it to hometown
right you know like the Final Four is
like to make the Final Four you're like
in a class of your own like to be top
four is there's top four and everyone
else and the women in the guys kind of
sense that so the week before is it's
like everything's heightened and you
just want to get to hometowns
do you read spoilers I hear spoilers
sometimes I'm do you know who wins this
season this is a no spoilers I'm so
excited to go
I know what happens okay interesting
which is a bummer because like I did a
while and I was really enjoying watching
is someone who like had no idea and then
like it's impossible like says something
like okay fine don't worry just tell me
it's hard it's really hard not to just
like click it until you read no so I
used to I spoiled Lauren B for me in bed
season and I hated the way that it felt
so I never did it again well 30 but in
my dm's and like just people like
sending it to me it's like I didn't ask
but they just say blank wins
I knew Vanessa one yeah and you guys
were not sipping deal Vanessa fine I
don't care
clearly no I mean we we try and see past
what we're shown it's like they and and
but Vanessa was like kind of a fan
favorite and ten maybe the very young
where there are some cracks but now I
live my life being like I'm not gonna
believe what the producers want me to
believe like they made that guy Jordan
the male model a villain and he ended up
being a good guy you know he's a funny
interesting guy I try not to to buy into
their artists I don't see a villain and
maybe it's cuz I've been on the show but
like I see like well you guys liked
Corinne love like Corinne is by all
standards the villain right we liked
Korean despite their efforts and I think
it was also because we met her early on
while yes as it was airing right know
every time we meet I'll automatically
like the contestants that follow me on
Instagram more and then it's what it is
Hannah G love her all I had to do way
back when ya know a low and slow it's
true I mean there was a lot of [ __ ] I
like wanted to talk about that guy but
you follow me on Instagram so like I
just didn't give it the effort you know
because my dismissiveness maybe that's
where it all started maybe Wow lesson
learned a my partner yeah unless and
learned to all future contestants just
saw a minister I'm a be nice to you yeah
okay
after Korean and also Olivia Creed II
who like was the villain of her season
and we had met her and she's just the
nicest person yeah and so then we
started to turn it on his head like this
season love Demi
so it's interesting safe to say that the
typical villains that you have met have
been some of the more interesting people
you know and like nice yeah and then we
could also see how the
they would say would come off in a weird
way on TV well I always on that show
right listen anyone anyone everyone is a
villain and a hero at any given moment
well you know no one for the most part
is as bad or as great as they come
across right because the show is very
simplified everyone gets siloed into a
character and if they want you to look
good they'll want you to look great yeah
and then if they want you to look bad
they'll make you look terrible when you
really watch it especially without the
music no one's really doing anything
nothing right and everyone's it's like
saying what we've all said we've all
talked [ __ ] we've all been caddy we've
all like had a funny look at her face
our cameras are on us 24/7 right and
when you're boring it's like we're gonna
burn or something or whatever and then
like you put that face with some sort of
comment I mean so stuff like that you
know listen there's exceptions every
rule there are some people from the
franchise I don't particularly care to
hang out with like mostly well I mean
I'm not a huge like I don't hang out
with Josh Murray you know like I don't
think it's a bad guy but like I you know
he's at any given moment you never
really know when the but we're also just
different people you know like the
Robbie's and Chase's of the world like I
don't have like they're just simple
creatures right different it's different
and it's fine right and I have friends
from the show but like again no one's
the hill hero villain I will say the
villains often tend to be people who
especially early on are the people where
the lead doesn't necessarily have a
romantic interest in and the people who
are also not afraid to just do and say
whatever they want right you guys would
easily be villains and I say that with
an iPod anymore is that like you're just
kind of like whatever [ __ ] it I'm going
to say whatever I'd love to say and
again like sometimes it can change like
the click with Korean like okay she had
a nanny I was like okay I'm only to meet
the nanny she's gonna go to hometowns
right and so that gave her time to like
kind of change her story arc right and
so like if I said if I send Korean home
week five or six
she never like has those moments for
people but actually she's kind of funny
and yeah you know Ashley like or
hanabi's Hanabi goes home like week four
or five she's just the bitter
and queen-like but like by the end when
she got sent home you're like this you
know she's probably like just a goofy
girl who I can relate to right yeah and
that's this kind of how this shows so do
you think Colton's keeping these people
around to give them that opportunity or
it or it's more orchestrated than it
varies I mean what I always said the
lead never the lead will never send home
women that they see a potential with and
by this stage in the game it's safe to
say that the lead has narrowed down in
their mind to two or three you always
try to keep an open mind right you
always try to give every woman or guy if
it's you're the Bachelorette you're in
front of like a chance to like move
things along and there are surprises at
times but like the heart wants what the
heart wants and usually you know so if
you if you have your favorite two or
three then like four or five it's like
yeah whatever like great you know and so
I will say though like most leads are
very worried about how they look and
especially with bachelor guys men tend
to be judged by their choices and women
yeah like I got a lot of heat for taking
Korean as far as I did yeah it was like
how could he be into the girl who like
but so did you take her in as far as you
did because you had an interest in her
or because she had this developing story
line was she had a nanny yeah okay
and again like no disrespect to Rin I
you know my connections with Vanessa
Rachel and in Raven were definitely
different and that's just like human
nature
yeah I thought crane was cool and like I
thought she was interesting she made me
laugh see buddy that jacket like yeah I
thought the hometown date was also have
the clothes that you bought you I think
so yeah there was this pea coat no that
I really liked it made no sense and like
friends like eyelids buy it I felt
really bad something like for how you do
it it was like $1,000 that is sad they
returned it but I was the only thing I
really wanted to see buy the clothes for
real or were they bought no the show did
not buy them really the show do you know
like if you want to drop a few bills
then it's on you Wow well I think I
don't think family business is doing
fine I think so do well so present day
you're doing your podcast all about
relationships
speaking of are you are you get are you
dating dating yeah that's it easier to
date people for you who are in the
bachelor world
are not high at this point stay away
from bachelor world I mean nothing you
know it's like there has to be a unique
situation it's too like it's too gossipy
and so yeah I certainly don't look at
evening every new season is like all
right what's so I try to like reach you
know like I have talked to some Colton's
women and their seasons more of like hey
if you have any questions and it's very
professional like let me know like
professionally like I can maybe
introduce you to some people but other
than that like I'm not you know yeah are
you want any amps there's the latest one
right I am oh you can talk about oh I'm
married
Raya Raya Raya Raya Raya Raya Raya so
you're both married yes yeah how's it
going gonna go well going great oh yeah
the wedding was great it was it made all
the planning really do you want kids
do you wanna get married we should have
done this before yeah I would love to
have kids how many uh well I mean as
many as she wants do you see any of your
your girls around town Corinne lives in
LA I like her in this week you did yeah
we're uh were we did a thing for People
magazine was it awkward it was fine so
it wasn't not awkward well it was like
what whatever
yeah I I'm very cautious around like and
Lana Corinne crane can be in the pain in
the ass I mean she can like one time she
randomly posted a photo of her and I
without a caption that was from our
hometown a year later and it was us like
I wake up and like the Internet thanks
for dating again for you I was [ __ ]
annoyed because it was more like you
know she it's like hey I haven't been
talked about in a month so I'm gonna
watch this picture well I'm so I try to
like I'm just like do I really like so I
was like I try to I just I'm on guard
when I'm around the women from my season
did you know when your season was airing
that there was a big rumor started by us
that Korean Won
you started the rumor well I mean art
meet her and were together and they made
her put on my engagement ring and take a
picture cuz I wanted to be Thursday in
Surrey
and honestly it worked so well but you
didn't see that it was remember
Hollywood I'm sorry look during when my
seasons going on there's a lot of
there's a lot of stuff and so you try to
stay out of it and also like
it wouldn't have bothered me actually
because she did win that win so like
actually that kind of makes it fun that
there's other rumors going
it was helpful thank you yeah so you
have you spoke to Rachael Raven came on
this show and had some words what'd she
say she said that you didn't have sex
that's true okay
what else did she say she knew that it
was Vanessa like she knew that when or
no she said the other she said the
opposite yeah no she really thought she
was gonna really thought she was gonna
win going
I was definitely a lie really yeah
explain like is it common well I mean on
rate like Rachael yeah she told Rachel
that she knew I was gonna pick Vanessa
and I won't get into details but like
like the fact like I went into fancy
Suites week 10th like I told the
producers listen I I'm pretty sure when
a pic Vanessa I want to try to make this
relationship work I'm not sleeping with
anyone else so we need to figure out how
to do this because they all go love
going in to listen like emotions are
heightened right and everyone who goes
in the fantasy suite for the first time
as a contestant there's an expectation
of like if I like this girl or like this
guy like it's gonna go down you know I
don't know what to think and especially
when it's the guy you know women I think
in general like if the the stereotype is
if a girl wants the hookup of course the
guy wants right right because guys know
and so but if by chance the guys like
hey listen we're not sleeping together
there's the fear of he won't pick me
right so like how do you go in and that
scenario where sex is an expectation and
suggests that there won't be any
sleeping together
and yet hey I might pick you you know so
why my plan was like I just kind of told
Rachel and Raven I wasn't sleeping with
anyone
I thought Raven III thought Raven being
that I've never slept with 20 anyone but
one person Olimpico Nick you're so
precious I was surprised by her reaction
at the time but ultimately like and so
that was like yeah she she knows right
like it was kind of this unspoken I mean
I didn't know first I can't confirm I
don't know like we didn't like have this
like conversation I know you're picking
Vanessa but I would have been surprised
if I think in that world sometimes Mike
because I you know I was really
crumbling Andi and Kaitlyn broke up with
me I was crushed and blindsided so when
I was a lead I had I had a lot of guilt
about like well I like making some I'm a
hypocrite like I have to do like I was
so like I was messed up for a few weeks
both times being like why did they say
this or why they do this or like it's
just you know in any break up like you
kind of always pine about like well but
you said this you kind of hang out I
think so when I was the bachelor I tried
to be very careful
like certainly I did like you know I
don't think she mentioned I definitely
asked Raven like what ring would she
want you know like certainly that was
probably dissing well that was dissing
jest right right
that was totally disingenuous but like
that's different than like the private
moments of off camera when someone says
I love you you're like well they're
saying it off camera this must mean
something well we have a physical
relationship like the you don't have to
do this as a lead so when the lead would
do things like off-camera
I always took it as like it meaning
something so I was very careful to like
so that when I would break up in any of
the women specifically like Rachel and
Raven if they were disappointed and I
didn't you know you never know like how
they're feeling yes but like if they
were disappointed I was my hope was they
would look back and be like okay yeah I
guess I kind of like yeah that didn't
happen or that right happening he never
said this so it kind of like because you
are caught up in the moment like you
were looking for signs but when you
leave leave the environment I was hoping
they would it would be easier to accept
because nothing really rat serious
happened right
you know like Raven and I like we never
really we never really talked about like
life after the
or things like that it was we had a
great time and I thought Raven was dope
yeah she was really cool and in just I
liked talking her and she was very aware
I thought she's really interesting and
she had a lot of cool things to say and
I enjoyed my time with her but it was
definitely different you know in terms
of yeah things we talked about so I
can't say that it was a lie maybe Raven
actually thought that but I do know that
she told Raven that but so who knows I
don't know he's a great podcast voice
you do a great talker yeah great orator
you have to hear myself so this are you
at what point did you know that it was
Vanessa because we always hear these
stories like all everyone knows that
it's gonna be this person but like at
what was it night one or like I mean
listen I I had an instant connection
with Vanessa when she a limo and but as
the lead same with Rachel too like
Rachel and that's why Rachel got the
first impression rose
Raven was kind of a surprise to me I I
didn't like that was more like after my
first date with her the purse was like
hey just she's really interesting and
she really was and I really was like I
enjoy being around Raven and people you
can talk to in that world is probably
one of the most important qualities yeah
yeah because most time you can only talk
there's nothing else and so yeah you
know I definitely my revenge was
probably always my number one but you're
always kind of like well I still have a
there's you don't get to hang out with
them right so like when I'm hanging out
with Vanessa because also I mean or
Rachel like I don't know Vanessa like I
got to know Vanessa but like you always
know that he only knows so much so
you're trying to figure out well if
Vanessa doesn't end up being who I think
she could be or what you know like what
about me and Rachel or what about me and
Raven so there's a lot of a lot of that
Wow
so even if you're like thinking I think
this could be my person you still kind
of go on the dates and it's a mental
game yeah it's tough it's not it's being
the lead is not easy would you ever do
it again no no I mean I'm done now that
I know and love you I want you back on
my show right paradise is fun paradise
would be the only thing I would never
I'm not gonna go on paradise but it's
fun you buddy are ten Duyck well it's
super fun like I had an enjoyable
experience
but it's stressful yeah too hot to
everyone sweating through this I had a
great time and Paradis is fun the other
ones are you have fun at times but it's
a lot of work it's it's just stressful
yeah and especially if you give a [ __ ]
yeah you care about someone it's like
like the Cassie and Kailyn that's why I
like I don't think it's disingenuous
because you can tell they're a little
[ __ ] up about it yeah yeah they may
leave the world and be like I guess I
really didn't like them that much but
what I'm saying in that moment they
believe what they're saying that's yeah
okay well thank you for being that
in-depth analysis everyone had a little
files podcast what's your next episode
come out it comes out every Wednesday
also natural habits I have an essential
oil company it's for anxiety and
headaches which is my anxiety boost
mental clarity their blends so we do you
say organic blends well you can diffuse
them bees are roll-ons your ethically on
your skin
Oh like perfume yeah well they're not
probably they absorb in your body
oh yes smells and where can everyone get
these natural habits and natural habits
an Instagram phone I think it's working
yeah I started using it for anxiety and
then I founded my own company which
starts from farms all over the world
that's so cool so you're a businessman
now good for my cancer that's our
business man
okay well keep up with nakhon and sir
I'm antic file always keep up with the
morning trust we're back tomorrow with a
podcast only episode and best friends
best friends well I did everything can
happen any you know what what is this
hey what did you say you guys say you
made up like some bucket or so this
makes it better or worse but it was
because of I'm blac Chyna
okay okay so who's in I know I used to
be in this so look this is your face we
crumpled you up because we took you out
make sure you use a good photo of you
that you like it's fine there was there
some not you could have picked less
flattering one yeah I mean so basically
this was just the best reach people are
these people I'll explain these are the
best kind of people we take umbrage with
and we started with blac Chyna because
like it was something in the
her with her everyday we saw her vagina
at 11 a.m. and it's just like it was a
lot for us honestly like it was a lot so
we were done with her
Jacob sorry this is he's like an 11 year
old like musically start open 11 you're
open he beat me out in the People's
Choice Award and his videos are really
upsetting and just like he like licks
his lips and like like aged kids
well he's problematic okay like sorry
and then this couldn't be more pertinent
Tristan third trimester sure yeah don't
[ __ ] with the Kardashians we put him in
here when the first cheating scandal
happen and like they were taking over
our lives can I ask you a question yeah
so he did it once and we all knew yeah
who's like who's to blame well clearly
he is to blame it wedding more Jordans
blame well sure - but what about I mean
Khloe knew he was a cheater this is so
shocking Oh cuz he cheated I think he's
been cheating and he'll cheat again
either and also is the first time he's
cheated since the last time it's the
Jordan woods if at all that's what
supercut and Jordans like Kylie's best
friend friend's sister
live godmother so that's it here you can
have this is Jordan not in there
actually she should be in good Jordan do
I think the 11-year old that's a little
no he's there for good it's forever okay
when he turns eight twenty I'm on your
show
he's 11 I think he's like 12 oh well
then it's fine
well I guess it's gonna be ending if you
keep showing up and taking people out
we'll fix it I feel like there's a lot
of people you can - my gun it's true
that's should we have to update it
well whatever least favorite of this
season ooh Oh Courtney Courtney Courtney
who's Courtney she was fighting with
Demi and she was I know the what Oh
Traci Traci Traci she's a wardrobe
stylist and her choices worried it was
on one episode with a bad at it no but
she Jackie's more than bad wardrobe
she's a stylist well but she should
otherwise tough to hit anyone no it was
because she showed up as the fashion
please and she needed to arrest herself
now I'm extra self-conscious about these
pants I went like I did
I'm afraid I'm gonna make you unemployed
expands working together watch shoes
pants topics men's fashion yeah I tried
let me try again thank you all for
watching have a great day
you